those moms and parents never get thanked
I in particular failed to thank one
so
if I can take this moment to thank
helgeby
um for not letting me write in cards
with boys till I was 18 because she was
right I would have done what she said I
was gonna do
for making me practice every day when I
got home piano ballet whatever it is I
wanted to be she said to be an artist
you had to practice every day and for
reminding her daughters that there's no
race no religion no class system no
color nothing no sexual orientation that
makes us better than anyone else
we are all deserving of love
So to that Trailblazer who allowed me to
have
that
in this and this I thank you so much for
this opportunity that I share with these
extraordinary women and my lover Meryl
Streep thank you
[Applause]